♪ [music] ♪
So at this stage of the process,
let's inquire all the inputs we
already have. In the context of a
discounted cash flow valuation,
we've talked about cash flows,
we've talked about coming
up with discount rates,
and we've talked about estimating growth.
In this session, I'd like to bring that
process to closure by looking at the
biggest number you often have in a
discounted cash flow valuation which is
the terminal value. So let's think about
why we need a terminal value to apply
closure in a discounted cash flow
valuation. The value of an asset is the
present value of its expected cash flows
over time, that's always true.
So if you have a 15-year asset,
you produce cash flows for the
next 15 years, you discount them back,
you have a value for the asset.
With a publicly traded company though,
your cash flows can go on and on and
on forever. You cannot estimate cash flows
forever, so here's what we do
in valuation. We estimate cash flows for a
finite period, 5 years, 10 years,
and at the end of the period,
we estimate a terminal value to capture
what we think this company will be worth
at the end of that period.
That terminal value is what we want to
talk about in this session. In practice,
there are three ways you would see people
estimating the terminal value.
The first is to use a stable growth rate.
Assume your cash flows grow at a constant
rate forever beyond year 5 or 10,
what does that get you?
It gets you an infinite series in
mathematics, which can be...which allows
you to compute the value by taking the
cash flow in the year after your
terminal year, year 11 if you're looking
at year 10 or year 6 if you're looking
at year 5, and dividing by the difference
between your discount rate and your
growth rate. It's called a perpetual
growth model. The second way you can
estimate a terminal value is to assume
that at the end of that 5 or 10
year period, you liquidate the company.
What does liquidation mean?
You sell off the assets of the company,
you get the best price you can for them
and use that as your estimated terminal
value. There's a third way of estimating
terminal value that many analysts use,
which I do not think fits,
and that is to assume that at the end of
year 5 or 10, your terminal value will be
a multiple of some operating metric.
For instance, in many discounted cash
flow valuations, the terminal value would
be 6 times EBITDA or 10 times earnings.
Think of where those 6 times and 10 times
come from. They come from looking at other
companies and what they trade at in the
market today. In other words,
you made the biggest number in your
discounted cash flow valuation a pricing,
and that basically undercuts the whole
notion of intrinsic value. So in effect,
there are two ways of estimating terminal
value. One is the perpetual growth model
and the other is liquidation value,
and for most healthy going concerns it's a
perpetual growth model that you will end
up using. So let's take a closer look
at that perpetual growth model.
To get my value in year 10,
I need my cash flow in year 11, and I need
a cost of capital and a growth rate to use
to get the terminal value,
that's if I'm valuing the entire firm.
If I'm valuing equity,
I need the cash flow to equity in year 11
and the cost of equity and the growth rate
forever beyond that point in time.
That equation is an incredibly powerful
one but it can very easily lead you into a
maze and cause you to lose control of your
discounted cash flow valuations.
So there are four simple rules I'm going
to suggest to keep your terminal value
in check. Here's the first one,
this growth rate that you're assuming is
your growth rate forever comes with a cap.
What do I mean by a cap?
When you tell me your cash flows will grow
at a fixed rate forever,
that growth rate has to be less than or
equal to the growth rate of the economy
in which you operate. Notice,
I've given you the freedom to define that
economy as the U.S. economy,
the global economy, or even a local
economy depending on the company you're
valuing, but it has to be less than or
equal to the growth rate of that economy.
Why? Because if you let this cash flow
grow at a rate faster than the growth rate
of the economy, your company,
sooner or later, will become the economy.
The challenge then becomes how do we
decide what the growth rate in the economy
is? I've suggested a simple rule in prior
sessions and that is to use your risk free
rate as your proxy for the growth rate
of the economy, and here's why it works.
Embedded in your risk-free rate is the
expected inflation which should help you
in your terminal growth rate.
Embedded in your risk-free rate is a real
interest rate, and in the long term, your
real interest rate and the real growth
rate in the economy have to converge.
It will keep your valuations disciplined,
it will keep your valuations also
from getting out of control.
Now notice I said that your growth rate
has to be less than or equal to the growth
rate of the economy. In 2017,
for instance, where the risk-free rate in
U.S. dollars was 2.1%,
the cap on your growth rate will also
become 2.1%. That is if you follow my
rigid rule of letting the risk-free rate
be a nominal growth rate,
but it doesn't have to be 2.1%.
It could be 1.5%, it could be 1%,
it can be 0%, it can be -2%.
It's a choice that many analysts don't
make, but you can let you cash flows
decline at a fixed rate beyond your
terminal year. What is that going to do to
your company? Your company will peak
in your 5 or 10 which is your last year of
calculation and then it will become
smaller over time before effectively
disappearing. So first rule is obey that
growth gap because if you violate that
rule, your terminal values will explode
on you. Here's a second suggestion,
don't wait too long to put your company
to stable growth. In my discounted cash
flow valuations of companies,
I almost never go beyond a 10-year growth
period. That strikes some people
as conservative because they will start
naming companies that have grown
for longer than 10 years. They'd say,
"What about Microsoft? What about Google?
What about Apple?" The very fact that we
can name these companies that have grown
for longer than 10 years should tell you
that they're the exceptions rather
than the rule. You should never value a
company to be an exception,
and 10 years is around the 90th or 95th
percentile of growth periods for high
growth companies. So when you look at
analysts projecting out 25 or 30 years
of growth, be cautious because those
growth periods could happen
but they're unlikely.
So cap your growth rate,
and don't wait too long to put
your company into stable growth.
So let me try this
on my companies and in doing this,
I'm going to draw on a very
simple proposition. It's not how quickly
you grow that I worry about,
it's how much value you create from that
growth. Let me back up.
If you grow but you grow by taking
projects around your cost of capital,
your growth has no value.
So when we talk about high growth periods
we're also talking about growth
accompanied by excess returns,
earning more than your cost of capital.
So the key question you need to ask when
you sit down to value your companies,
what are my company's competitive
advantages and how sustainable are they?
The bigger your competitive advantages and
the more sustainable they are,
the longer your growth period can be.
And so if you have a company like
Coca-Cola which is one of the most
valuable brand names in the world,
you can see why your growth period might
be 10 years. But if you have competitive
advantages that are minor or can be very
quickly chipped away by competition,
you should be a lot more cautious about
long growth periods.
The scaling factor should also be taken
into account. If your company is a small
company in a big market,
you can allow for long growth periods,
but if it's a large company in a
mature market, you need to be a lot more
cautious. So let's try this for the
companies that I'm looking at.
Let me start with Disney.
I'm going to give Disney a 10 year growth
period. Before you get too excited,
I'm not going to give it too high a growth
rate, only 6.8% but I'm going to allow it
to grow for 10 years because I think
Disney has very strong
competitive advantages. After all,
you can't recreate Mickey.
Next, let me move to Vale,
I'm going to treat Vale as a
mature company. It's a global mining
company, it's already one of the largest
iron ore mining companies in the world,
it is the largest iron ore mining company
in the world. I can't see it growing at
10%, 12%, or 15% a year so I'm going
to make it a mature company which means
that I don't have a growth period
to estimate. Let's move on to Tata Motors.
I'm going to give Tata Motors a growth
period of about five years,
and I think the growth is going to come,
not from its domestic production alone but
from Jaguar and Land Rover continuing
to grow in global markets.
A combination of being in a very large
growing market, which is India,
for automobiles and Jaguar and Land Rover
is going to give it some growth but I'm
going to be cautious.
I'm going to be cautious because
Tata Motors is part of a business,
the automobile business,
where earning more than the cost
of capital is more the exception than the
rule, so I'm going to give them a five
year growth period. So Disney has a 10
year growth period, Vale is a mature
company already, Tata Motors has a five
year growth period. Let me close
off by looking at Baidu.
Baidu has two advantages,
one is it in a large and growing market,
the Chinese online market, and it's also
got a dominant position at market partly
because the Chinese government has stepped
in and kept the competition out.
For those two reasons,
I'm going to give it a 10 year growth
period. So 10, 5, 0,
and 10 for the four companies reflecting
very different competitive advantages and
sustainability in each of these companies.
So that's what I'd like you to do for your
company next. You've talked about growth,
you've estimated a growth rate, but make
this valuation yours by thinking about
your company's competitive advantages.
How long the growth will last,
and then putting your company
into stable growth. We'll talk next about
what parameters you might have to change
when you make your company
a mature company.
♪ [music] ♪